since apex legends launched in 2019 the
respawn team has added a ton to the game
new legends maps abilities lore you name
it with so much to dig into here are 9
things you might not know about apex
legends octane the high-energy
death-defying stuntman was first added
back in season 1 of apex but you might
not know that his origins actually lie
in the titanfall 2 speedrunning
community if you played titanfall 2 you
might remember it's gauntlet a
replayable tutorial area with a
tantalizing leader board that just
begged you to try it over and over again
cash mayo rose to the challenge
completing the gauntlet in 12 seconds
flat by using frag grenades to give
themselves a speed boost the team at
respawn were clearly impressed and
incorporated this into octane's stuntman
backstory he set the course record on
the gauntlet by using a grenade to
propel himself across the finish line
resulting in him losing both legs and if
you're wondering if cash mayo's 12
second gauntlet record still stands
it doesn't cash mayo has now managed to
complete the feat in a little over 10
seconds if there's one thing i know
about mirage it's that he loves pork
chops it's a good day to take out some
fools and be back in time for dinner got
pork chops tonight love pork chops so
much so in fact that his recipe is
included on one of the game's loading
screens andrew rayer more commonly known
for his youtube series binging with
babish made mirage's pork chops exactly
how the recipe calls for adding 15 grams
of ground cloves and an additional 15
grams of ground cinnamon and as
predicted this is unpalatable and i'm
not saying that to be a snob it tastes
like i just poured the bottle of ground
cloves into my eyes and mouth turns out
that manny hagopian the writer
responsible for mirage's recipe made a
slight error when converting it to the
metric system manny came up with a
revised recipe which babish made and
gave his seal of approval to mirage
isn't the only legend with a go-to
recipe lifeline's cookies and mad
maggie's warrior feast are also both
supposed to be delicious
back in 2020 respawn ran the grand
soiree arcade event and one of the
limited time modes let you play the game
in third person while the mode was
short-lived you can still play in the
third person in the game but only in the
firing range just by following some
simple steps the elephant in the room
with apex is that it's made by the
titanfall team it's set in the same
universe as titanfall some characters
and loadouts are even from titanfall
so how come there are no titans in the
game while the apex team has tried to
add them multiple times internally but
the titans cause balance issues that the
team hasn't found the right solution to
like how do you make a battle royale map
suitable for the giant titans how do you
account for the titan's vast health pool
while the team has gone on record to say
never say never with regard to adding
them to the game they're not on the road
map right now so titans may not have
made it to apex but plenty of characters
from the titanfall games have honestly i
could make a whole video about these
connections but here are some key ones
you might have missed valkyrie for
example is the daughter of viper you may
remember him as being the pilot of the
jerk titan that ripped off bt's arm in
titanfall 2.
valkyrie real name kairi imahara even
had fellow legend rampart use the flight
core from her dad's titan to make the
jetpack she uses for the apex games
mirage is the nephew of draws who helps
cooper and bt hijack the ims malta and
provided covering fire when cooper went
head to head with viper three legends
were previously titan pilots wraith ash
and newcastle while technically valkyrie
has piloted a titan before she didn't
complete her training to become a fully
fledged pilot octane owns a titan but he
isn't a pilot he just keeps one covered
in graffiti in his massive house
wraith wasn't in titanfall 1 and 2 but
she's got a cool link to the titanfall
games nonetheless she's from an
alternate dimension where the bad guys
from titanfall 2 actually won this ties
into her in-game abilities to be able to
hear warning voices which are her from
other dimensions and of course her
ability to use a dimensional rift to get
out of trouble while there are obviously
many titanfall easter eggs to enjoy in
apex legends references to other games
are hidden throughout for example
watson's strange attractor skin is
clearly a reference to samus from
metroid even down to the teal braces
mimicking samus's arm cannon krypto's
devil's advocate skin is a devil may cry
reference with the red coat and black
shirt looking a hell of a lot like
dante's usual get up pathfinder has a
banner pose called for the birds where
he gets attacked by a raven clearly an
ode to overwatch's bastion who has a
bird friend named ganymede it even
translates to weapons the mastiff has a
legendary skin called warp zone the name
itself is a reference to shortcuts from
super mario bros but the skin is teeming
with references to video games from nez
buttons and cartridge slot to a usb
connector and even a little screen now
while this character looks like a little
mega man it was actually confirmed by
apex senior producer josh medina to be
pixel jack cooper from titan tunes a
titanfall cartoon series made by respawn
animator muay para back at the 2019 game
awards mirage appeared in a video call
with host jeff keeley to announce that
year's winter event mirage's hollow day
bash tell me tell me did i already win
for best all-around competitor in a
battle royale based on skills but mostly
good looks
that is such a specific award as i told
you on twitter does not exist while it
may have looked like it was pre-recorded
and made specifically for the show it
was actually done live mirage's actor
roger craig smith was decked in a
performance capture outfit and was
speaking to jeff who was on stage at the
microsoft theater across the street the
stunt was a collaboration between
respawn and a creative technology studio
called the mill where they utilized
real-time rendered shooting tech to
shoot and animate the skit here's a
weird one that you might not know many
of the legends may look spry and
energetic but several of them are
actually over 100 years old horizon for
example is 37 but she was trapped in a
black hole for a few decades making her
roughly 125 years old ash is 121 and
also spent a few years with her head
shattered in another dimension but
that's a story for a different video and
revenant is an astonishing 313.
the youngest legend is rampart she's
only 21. okay this one's cheating
because it's a titanfall easter egg but
an apex dev helped bring it to light so
i'm counting it here a titanfall 2
easter egg went unnoticed for over five
years until respawn's narrative
historian david bartle dropped a couple
of hints on his twitter account as to
its location turns out in titanfall 2's
infamous time travelling effect and
cause mission if you time swapped 88
times outside a certain door the room
changes into a
weird one where a dead soldier's body
lies on the floor while another is
doing the splits between two kitchen
countertops
definitely a weird one but one that
remained hidden for an awfully long time
it was the creation of respawn senior
designer jake keating so there you have
it nine things you may not know about
apex legends for more on the game make
sure you check out jordan's weekly
column hot drop over on gamespot.com or
subscribe to the channel for more
features like this one if you've got any
apex tidbits drop them in the comments
below or come find me on twitter i'm at
lucy james games catch you next time